[Music]
long for kids since I was very very
young the way you talk about children is
it something that do you think about in
the near future I can't wait for today
thank you we'll start us on me
that's forward to May 6 2019 I'm very
excited to announce that baby boy this
morning
Prince Harry was ecstatic to announce
the birth of his first child with Megan
Markel now almost six weeks later the
Duke is celebrating his first Father's
Day in the sweetest way
peekaboo yes that's little Archie
Harrison mountbatten-windsor peering
over his daddy's finger while being
cradled on his lap the Sussex duo
instagrammed the sweet snap on Sunday
along with the caption Happy Father's
Day and wishing a very special first
Father's Day to the Duke of Sussex I
have the two best guys in the world
while the couple has shared several
photos of their son including this
heartwarming shot of his feet they
posted on Mother's Day this black and
white snap is the first clear look we've
gotten of Archie's adorable phase this
is definitely my first last week royal
expert Katie Nichol told ET why this
holiday is so important to Prince Harry
he waited for a very long time to become
a father there were moments when he
feared he never would become a dad so to
mark Father's Day with baby Archie is
going to be really special what's more
we're told Archie has even helped mend
Harry's once tense relationship with his
brother Prince William I think things
got better in the lead-up to the birth
of course just before Archie was born
William and Kate went to visit the
Sussex is I certainly think now that
Archie is here it has probably really
helped to improve the relationship
William is over the moon that his
brother is a dad very reason
patience society parenting and we're
told Harry is a very hands-on Papa Harry
has been changing nappies Megan clean up
in the night she's nursing so feeding on
demand really every few hours apparently
he's a hungry little baby
congratulations to this first-time dad
we just were just so thrilled to have
have our own little bundle of joy
dispensing precious times with them as a
stone slowly starts to grow up
[Music]